und wir gehen zunächst nach kiew zu ihm
zur anzahl der dort in den straßen von
kiew steht vor einem zelt des roten
kreuzes beschreibe einmal wo du gerade
bist paul und was du heute an diesem
kriegstag 18 in dieser kriegs hauptstadt
erlebt ja klar das ist hier die
stadtgrenze sozusagen zur queen die geht
dort runter und wenn ich hier mal ein
mal sie zeigen kann das sind sozusagen
die gehen die in die evakuiert worden
sind hier in den letzten stunden und ich
will einmal zeigen jorge celio hier
fördert
also wenn wir hier sozusagen die
menschen den teilweise haben sie presse
aufkleber auf ihren helmen um dort sich
heraus zu bekommen ich zeige ich euch
das einmal das ist die richtung des
checkpoints und hier sehen wir wie eine
familie rausgeholt wird
die tatsächlich den presse aufkleber auf
ihrem helm hat eben um sicher zu sein
und da sozusagen sich herauszukommen und
sich zu krankenwagen überall und in die
richtung das ist der checkpoint
richtung ihn die immer noch beschossene
der beschossenen vor ort in diese
richtung ein ungefähr 500 meter weiter
hat man kein handyempfang deswegen
stehen wir hier momentan wir gehen auch
gleich weiter rein aber dann kommt immer
wieder krankenwagen raus wir zeigen dass
wir hier völlig geschwächte menschen die
aus ihren vielen rausgekommen sind da
sind natürlich viele alte menschen
darunter das sind viele menschen die
tagelang in bunkern standen die nicht
rausgekommen sind
die nicht rausgekommen sind aus ihrer
wohnung und jetzt hier zumindest erst
einmal ein bisschen sicherer sind in
dieser situation da sind helfer vor ort
aber es sind längst nicht genügend
helfer die hier sind was sagt das über
die lage dann in alpinen also auf der
anderen seite aus paul wenn selbst diese
menschen die die sich ja erstmal
entschieden haben oder zwangsläufig erst
mal bleiben mussten wenn selbst die
jetzt heraus müssen koste es was es
wolle
ja die evakuierungen sind sehr langsam
bin weil der beschuss in dieser stadt
extrem ist also wir hören auch hier vor
fünf minuten grad
einschläge in dieser richtung und wir
hören immer wieder dass hier vor ort
unter beschuss steht vielleicht zeigen
wir das noch einmal hier wir sehen eine
völlig verzweifelte frau an einem völlig
verzweifelter mann der gerade dort
rausgekommen ist viele weinen bestimmt
glücklich
geschwächt und wissen nicht wohin mit
ihnen man muss sich das vorstellen teil
dieser menschen die alles hinter sich
gelassen haben die die nicht wissen was
sie jetzt in der nächsten zeit machen
werden denn sie haben den ort verlassen
viele haben ihr haus verloren viele
wissen gar nicht wo sie jetzt hin sollen
das ist ja nur die erste station hier
raus erst mal in sicherheit das ist
natürlich eine gute nachricht wir sehen
immer wieder wie hier menschen zusammen
brechen sie können einfach nicht mehr
und das zu erleben in ihrer stadt und
ich habe gerade mit einer frau
gesprochen die zu mir gesagt hat ich
hätte sich niemals vorstellen können
dass wirklich hier bei ihnen kriegt
aussprechen würde ja wir sehen jetzt um
dich herum tatsächlich viele alte
menschen paul das ist ein ganz anderes
bild als vor einigen tagen noch als wir
frauen kinder dort auf der flucht
gesehen habt auf dem weg dort an die
stadtgrenze wer lebt denn in kiew
aktuell noch wenn man das überhaupt
leben nennen kann also sind dann
sozusagen ausschließlich kämpfer übrig
geblieben
nein kein tier sind immer noch fast die
hälfte der anwohner dass in zwei
millionen menschen die noch dort sind
und es werden weniger aber
erstaunlicherweise wollen in china auch
dort bleiben viele wollen in kiel
bleiben viele sagen wir lassen unsere
stadt nicht zurück wie überlassen sie
nicht plane ich mit putin und den
russischen truppen sondern wir wollen da
bleiben ist dieses bild was ihr auch
natürlich zeigt vermeiden zb diese
kamera wie man dort immer sieht die ist
am ende
etwas irreführend denn es sieht so aus
als wenn die stadt bereits komplett leer
wir sehen wir uns wieder menschen die
aus ihren penis hier ankommen an diesen
check point hey das ist ein strom der
nicht aufhört und immer wieder kommen
auch krankenwagen hier an menschen
meistens nur mit einer tüte ganz wenig
habseligkeiten die sie mit raus
schleppen konnten aber im tier ist der
eindruck wenn man diese bilder sieht
diese live kameras dass es sozusagen
schon komplett leer wäre das ist es
nicht das sind immer noch mindestens
sagt er wieder den krieg oder
bürgermeister zwei millionen menschen in
der stadt
erlebst du paul die lage in der
hauptstadt jetzt kommen auch die
einschläge immer immer noch näher
russische panzer die immer noch noch
näher an die hauptstadt heranrücken
ja wir hören dass rund 15 kilometer
entfernt die nächste linie ist sozusagen
von der innenstadt ist und wir müssen
jederzeit davon ausgehen dass dieser ja
dass dieser angriff auf die hauptstadt
kommen wird
wir hören jetzt hier ausgehen dass
gerade natürlich von dieser stelle man
muss immer mal wieder sich umschauen
entschuldigung das ist sozusagen etwas
womit mittlerweile die klever jede
sekunde jede minute jede stunde rechnen
müssen dass es passiert dann schauen wir
noch an einer gemeinsamen paul auf das
was der ukrainische präsident vor
wenigen stunden gesagt hat hat sich dann
auch noch so humanitären lage geäußert
blogger selensky
die vereinbarten humanitären korridore
funktionieren 12.700 29 menschen konnten
evakuiert werden die hilfstransporte für
mario pohl werden am nachmittag die
stadt erreichen sie konnten nicht auf
direktem weg in die stadt fahren sondern
mussten außerhalb über nacht halten
der präsident der sich wieder an seine
landsleute an die ukraine wendet paul du
stehst an der stadtgrenze dort die ist
im moment wie wird der präsident im
moment wahrgenommen wie hat sich das in
diesen 18 kriegstagen verändert ich
stelle mir das wahnsinnig schwierig vor
aktuell tage an denen man ganz
kämpferisches durchhält und so weiter
aber jetzt haben wir 18 diese machen
der präsident wird immer noch als sehr
stark wahrgenommen das muss man ganz
klar so sagen kann und ich denke daran
wird sich auch so lange nicht ändern bis
eher schmerzhafte entscheidung treffen
muss denn am ende ist es der präsident
der entscheiden muss was ist er putin
bereit zu geben was ist er russland
bereit zu geben bei den verhandlungen
und dann werden wir die brüche sehen die
es dort gibt momentan sind weiter die
ukrainerin und keiner im kampfmodus im
kriegs modus sie werden immer wieder von
blutigen lenski sozusagen darin bestärkt
weiterzumachen und das ist auch ein
bisschen die angst die furcht dass
dieser widerstand der letzte nachdem
tage schwächer werden könnte man darf
das ja nicht vergessen die ukraine
kämpfen seit 18 tagen auch die soldaten
natürlich an der pont insbesondere und
die russische armee die schickt immer
weiter nachschub neues personal frisches
personal büsche soldaten die dort
angekommen und erneut versuchen hier
einzudringen und das ist natürlich ein
zermürbender krieg der dort geführt wird
wenn sie mögen der krieg sagt paul
ronzheimer dort in den straßen chaos der
kriegs hauptstadt beziehungsweise ganz
an der stadtgrenze der ukrainischen
hauptstadt dort wo jetzt auch als kranke
alles rausgeholt werden aus alpinen dort
an eine versorgungsstation des roten
kreuzes an der stadtgrenze von kiew
danke für den moment paul ronzheimer